THREE DALLY DODD THE RAZA
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA WIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN
HOTEL ABODE. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK I DON'T.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE REAL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA SENATOR LIKE HEALTHY.
BERMAN GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL
GOD IT'S MUSLIMS THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD OBSERVE RAMADAN WE PRAY
IN GRATITUDE FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO THE FIVE PILLARS
OF ISLAM PROFESSION OF FAITH
PRAYER ALMSGIVING FASTING AND
PILGRIMAGE MAY EACH OF US FROM
OUR OWN PERSPECTIVE IMITATE THE
PERSEVERANCE AND DEDICATION BY
ACTING ON OUR DEEPEST BELIEVES
ME THE FRUITS OF OUR SINCERE
PRAYER RESULT IN JUST AND
GENEROUS LAWS TAKE RISE UP THE
DOWNTRODDEN NDT MAYOR EMPATHY
FOR THE SUFFERING OF THE POOR
REMIND US THAT WE CAN LIVE
SIMPLY SO THAT OTHERS MAY
SIMPLY LIVE. IN WHEN WE TRAVEL
ABROAD MAY WE APPROACH EACH
PLACE WITH THE REFERENCE OF A
PILGRIMAGE KNOWING THAT WE ARE
ON HOLY GROUND TREATING EACH
OTHER AS BROTHERS AND SISTERS
OF ONE CREATOR WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME ON THAT. PLEASE PUT
YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEART AS WE
HONOR OUR MEN AND WOMEN ARE
SERVING OUR GREAT COUNTRY. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
LIMóN AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATORS
WELCOME. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SEEING
NONE. CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
FILE. SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED
WITH AMENDMENTS THREE FIFTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY EIGHT SENATE
BILL SIXTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SEVENTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS TO
SEVENTY MADAM SECRETARY THE
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY SENATOR SKINNER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHTY SIX BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES AND
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. UNDER
SKINNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
SB EIGHTY SIX IS A SOME
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO OUR
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS BILL AND
OUR PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
TRAILER BILL WHICH WAS ONE THE
MAJOR COMPONENTS OF WHAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU IS THAT AS WE
HAD TO PASSED IN THAT ORIGINAL
BILL WE WERE INTO OUR INTENTION
WAS TO PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS STIMULUS PAYMENTS TO R.
S. S. I. N. S. S. P.
RECIPIENTS. AND WHAT THIS BILL
pFIX TO ENABLE US THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO THAT- WE ALSO
IN THIS BILL EXEMPTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FROM REQUIREMENTS TO CONTRACT.
WITH THE U. S. SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TO
ISSUE THAT ONE TIME INCREASE TO
OUR SS SINUSES P. RECIPIENTS.
THESE CHANGES RESOLVE
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS AND
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT AS I
MENTIONED TO BE ABLE TO
PROMPTLY ISSUE THOSE PAYMENTS.
THE BILL ALSO MAKE SOME CHANGES
TO HELP IMPLEMENTED BARCODE
NINETEEN SUPPORTS IN OUR SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS. AND IT
APPROPRIATES ONE POINT TWO
MILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. TO IMPLEMENT
PROVISIONS RELATING TO FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENTS WHILE WE ARE
INTO THIS CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING CENTER
NIELSEN BUT PRESENT LAYS ON THE
SENATE THIS PARTICULAR BILL I
THINK IS OKAY BUT TAKEN IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE REST OF THE
BUDGET I THINK I'M GOING TO
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS WITH OTHER
BILLS AS A CRUISE SHIP THEY
HAD. IN PART BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK WE'VE HAD SUFFICIENT TIME
THE REPUBLICANS TO REVIEW WHO
HAD ALMOST NO ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER NIELSEN ELSON ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
FIVE BATES. BAKER FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY. DODD HI THE
RAZA HI EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO- HI HURTADO. JONES.
KAMLAGER FIVE LAYERED HI LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. PHOTOBOOK HI
PAN HI PORTANTINO. HI ROTH.
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI HI NUMBER
FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WIENER.
HI WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES JEFF FOR JUST.
DALLY. GROVE HURTADO HI JONES.
MELENDEZ NIELSEN. ROTH WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BASED PORGES. DALLY THE GROWTH.
JONES MELENDEZ. NIELSEN RICHARD
S. B. ROTH HI. WILK. FIVE
THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
SKINNER M. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINETY THREE
BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW. AFTER
LEADING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I'M- PLEASED TO BRING YOU AB.
SB NINETY THREE WHICH WAS HEARD
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE ON- THIS
PAST MONDAY AND- WHAT THIS BILL
DOES NOW THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT- THE VIRUS THE
CODE NINETEEN BEHAVING. THAT WE
WILL HAVE A KANEMI WIDE OPENING
BY JUNE FIFTEENTH WE KNOW THAT
MANY OF THE SECTORS THAT WERE
COMPLETELY CLOSED DUE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WILL
BE RE OPENING. THE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR SO JOBS IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY. CONVENTION CENTERS
AIRPORTS AND SUCH WAS THE
SECTOR THAT LOST THE MOST JOBS.
DUE TO THE NEED TO CLOSE
FACILITIES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THOSE JOBS ARE NOW
BEGINNING TO BE RESTORED. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW FOR
THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO HAD WORKED
FOR THE FACILITY FOR A MINIMUM
OF SIX MONTHS. TO BE INFORMED
BY THEIR EMPLOYER THAT THEY ARE
RE HIRING THE EMPLOYEE THEN HAS
FIVE DAYS TO RESPOND SO THAT
THEY CAN TAKE BACK THE JOB THAT
THEY HAD SO IT IS NOT THAT THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO ANY JOB AT THE
FACILITY. AND IT IS NOT FOR ANY
PAST EMPLOYEE IS ONLY EMPLOYEES
WHO WERE LAID OFF DUE TO THIS
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROVISIONS
ONLY APPLY TO HOTELS WITH MORE
THAN FIFTY GUEST ROOMS LARGE
CONVENTION CENTERS WITH MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND SEATS
AIRPORTS AND BUILDING SERVICES
FOR COMMERCIAL. BUILDINGS THE
ENFORCEMENT IS EXCLUSIVELY IN
THE HANDS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. AND THERE IS NO
PRIVATE ACTION RIGHT OF ACTION
IN THIS BILL ADITIONALLY THESE
PROVISIONS SUNSET ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. NOW IF AND- THOSE OF US
WHO PAID ATTENTION TO THE- LOSS
OF JOBS DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THE SUBSEQUENT
WHAT THE SUBSEQUENT A
CIRCUMSTANCE WAS FOR MANY
PEOPLE WHO LOST JOBS THE OLDER
YOU WERE WHEN YOU LOST THAT JOB
AND THE LONGER YOU WERE OUT OF
A JOB SO IF YOU WERE OUT OF A
JOB FOR A YEAR OR MORE. AND
OVER AGE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LIKELIHOOD TO RETURN TO FULL
EMPLOYMENT BECAME LOWER WITH
EACH YEAR OF YOUR AGE AND YOUR
LIFE AND YOUR ABILITY TO GET RE
HIRED WENT FROM IF YOU LOOK AT
EVERYONE FROM EIGHT UNDER AGE
FORTY FIVE THEIR AVERAGE
ABILITY GET REHIRED WAS WITHIN
TWENTY WEEKS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OLDER WORKERS IT WAS A YEAR AND
LONGER ON AVERAGE. WE DO NOT
WANT TO HAVE A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE AS THE ECONOMY REOPENS WE
HAVE. OLDER WORKERS WHO ARE
CLOSER TO RETIREMENT AND WHO
THEN WOULD BE MORE DEPENDENT ON
OUR SAFETY NET IF THEY ARE NOT
RE EMPLOYED. TO BE IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THEY STAY
PERMANENTLY UNEMPLOYED. THE AB
OR SB NINETY THREE ALSO
APPROPRIATE SIX MILLION FROM
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUND FOR STAFFING
RESOURCES. AND- LASTLY I WANTED
TO SAY IS THAT ADDITIONALLY
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
THE DATA ON WHO LOST JOBS IN
THIS SECTOR IT WAS LARGELY
WOMEN AND IF WE LOOK AT THE
MOST RECENT UNEMPLOYMENT A
LAYOFF NUMBERS WOMEN WERE. LOST
MORE JOBS AND LEFT THE WORK
FORCE IN GREATER NUMBERS THAN
MEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC
RECESSION SO YOU COULD ALSO
LOOK AT THIS BILL IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TO GET WOMEN
BACK INTO THE WORK FORCE. AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR BORDERS. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT IF I MAY NOT
POSE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
SANDERS CAN WE TAKE A QUESTION.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU I
THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
I HAD I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OTHER FOLKS THAT HAVE A NUMBER
OF PROCEDURAL CONCERNS THAT
THIS IS A POLICY BILL- IN THE
MIDST OF A- CALL BUDGET BILL
BUT MY QUESTION TO YOU IS. WHEN
YOU HAVE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
SEEKING TO RE OPEN. I KNOW
THERE'S A NATURAL INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO WANT TO RE HIRE- FROM
THEIR PREVIOUS TALENT POOL. I
THINK THE INCLINATION IS WHAT
IS ALREADY THERE. BUT ONE OF
THE CONCERN I HAVE. IS THAT. IF
THIS IS BASED ON SENIORITY THE
REHIRING IS BASED ON SENIORITY.
WHAT IF THE WHAT IS THE
BUSINESS FOR EXAMPLE WANTED TO
HIRE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED. FIVE SO HOW WOULD
THAT FIT INTO A PRIORITY LIST-
WITH A BILL LIKE THIS. CENTER
SKINNER THANK YOU THREE HIRING
THE TERM SENIORITY YES THIS IS
IN THE PROVISIONS HOWEVER. THE
EMPLOYEE THAT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
RE HIRE MUST BE AN EMPLOYEE WHO
HAD THAT JOB WE'RE VERY
COMPARABLE JOB AND WORKED FOR
AT LEAST SIX MONTHS SO THEY A
EMPLOYEE WITH QUOTE UNQUOTE
SENIORITY. FIFTY FIFTY SECTOR
THAT THIS AFFECTS. MUCH THREE
HIGHER IN A DIFFERENT CATEGORY
OF JOB. SOMEONE WITH SENIORITY
IN A NOTHER JOB DOES NOT GET
THE JOB SO I WANTED TO JUST BE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT JUST A
BLANKET REQUIRED ANYONE WHO WAS
LAID OFF BUT RATHER IT MUST BE
WITHIN THE JOB CATEGORY. THAT
THE PERSON HAD. BUT THAT IS
MADAM PRESIDENT I MAY REAFFIRM
I THINK THE QUESTION IS WHAT IF
THE EMPLOYER WISH TO IMPLEMENT
A POLICY ON PUBLIC HEALTH
GROUNDS THAT THE PREFERENCE IS
THAT EMPLOYEES AT A REHIRE OR
THOSE WHO ARE VACCINATED. HOW
DOES THAT JIVE WITH. THE
SENIORITY POLICY LIKE THIS.
CENTERS AND- PROVISION
REGARDING THE EITHER
REQUIREMENT OR PREFERENCE
REGARDING VACCINATIONS AND- IT
IS NOT CLEAR TO ME THAT EVEN IF
THIS WERE ADDRESS THAT THAT
WOULD BE LEGALLY IF WE WOULD BE
LEGALLY ABLE TO DO SO- AND I
WILL DEFINITELY. GET STAFF TO
LOOK INTO THE LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT WHICH I
CANNOT SPEAK TO AS I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU BUY I THINK THERE
ARE ISSUES REDUCE RELATED TO
THE LEGALITY OF SUCH A
REQUIREMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER BOARD JUSTICE CENTER
NIELSEN. BERMAN PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE
I URGE A NO VOTE. THIS IS.
USING THE ACCESS TO THE
POLICIES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE ADMINISTRATION
IN FACT IN DEALING WITH THE
CULVERT SITUATION AND THE
DEVASTATION TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
A CAREER IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY. THAT WAS CONCERTED
EFFORT. IT COULD HAVE BEEN DONE
BETTER BY THIS ADMINISTRATION
IT WAS. AND NOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SAY PAY THE PRICE AND
LIKE MAKING A HOLE ALL OF THOSE
PLAYERS THAT WERE DISPLACED BY
ACTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR. AND I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND VERY MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES IN YOUR
DISTRICTS WHO WILL SAY OH BOY
THIS IS A GREAT DEAL I WANT TO
BRING ALL MY EMPLOYEES BACK
THAT'S THE GUY'S IN THERE FOR
FOOLISH. THE TEMPTATION OF THIS
LITTLE KNOWN ABOUT IT IT'S
GOING TO SUNSET. BUT WHO KNOWS
WHAT WILL HAPPEN COME SUNSET
TAX. I THINK THIS IS A RUSE AND
I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I JUST
PRO THE QUESTION THAT THE
SENATOR FROM FRESNO ASKED I CAN
ANSWER I ACTUALLY EMPLOY PEOPLE
YOU CANNOT ASK. AN EMPLOYEE
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN VACCINATED
OR NOT THERE'S HIPAA LAWS
THERE'S SO MANY LAWS THAT ARE
PROTECT THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF A
PERSON TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
MEDICAL INFORMATION PRIVATE AND
SO THIS BILL DOESN'T TALK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE IT WOULD BE ILLEGAL
TO DO THAT SO FOR I JUST WANTED
TO HELP ANSWER THAT QUESTION
I'M AN EMPLOYER I KNOW THE LAW.
AND THE LAW SAYS THAT YOU CAN
ASK WHEN YOU POISON YOU CAN'T
USE THAT AS A HIRING A COOK-
DETERMINATION EITHER IT'S
DISCRIMINATION SO I JUST WANT
TO SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY. CENTER
ROTH. THANK YOU- YOUR MANTRA
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT. ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM. FRESNO I
THINK WAS ANSWERED YOU KNOW-
THIS RECALL PROCESS HAS BEEN
GOING ON VARIETY OF SETTINGS
WITH THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WHEN WE BROUGHT
EMPLOYEES BACK FROM STRIKES.
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS WHEN THEIR
STRIKE ISSUES WHEN THEIR LAYOFF
ISSUES THIS THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY FOLLOWS THAT SAME
PROCEDURE. THERE'S SOME.
PROCESS ISSUES THAT WILL NEED
TO BE SORTED THROUGH BETWEEN
NOW AND THE TIME THAT WE- BUT
ON OUR LAST CLEAN OF BILLS THAT
ARE RELATIVELY MINOR BUT ARE OF
CONCERN TO BUSINESS. AS TO THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION IS THE
VACCINES. THE EMPLOYERS RUN THE
RECALL LIST BUT THE VACCINE
ISSUE IS A SEPARATE ISSUE AND
IF AN EMPLOYEE OF A PRIVATE
EMPLOYER. UNDER APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES WANTS TO IMPOSE A
MANDATORY VACCINE RULE FOR ITS
WORKFORCE. SHAMING THE LAW
CONTINUES TO PERMIT THAT THE
EMPLOYER IMPOSES A MATTER
MANDATORY VACCINE REQUIREMENTS
EMPLOYEES WHO ACCEPTED RECALL.
MAY OR MAY NOT MEET THAT TEST.
AND THEN THEY DROP OUT IN THE
EMPLOYER FILLS A POSITION SO
THAT'S HOW. BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE THE VACCINE ISSUE
AND THE MANDATORY IMPOSITION OF
A VACCINE RULE. INTERSECTS WITH
THIS RECALL FROM LAYOFF POLICY
HOPE THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
CENTER ROBSON CENTER PAM NO
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO SPEAK. SEEING AND
HEARING THAT SENATOR SKINNER
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE OF. THAT IS RAPE AND
RAISED A NUMBER OF TIMES ABOUT.
WHETHER THIS IS APPROPRIATE
BUDGET ACTION AND IF WE LOOK AT
THE ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TAKING SINCE JANUARY. THAT ARE
IMMEDIATE RESPONSES TO OUR
COVERED NINETEEN. PANDEMIC IN
CRISIS. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO MY KNOWLEDGE HAS NEVER
PROVIDED DIRECTIONLESS GRANTS
BEFORE TO- CERTAIN OF ITS-
CATEGORY OF RESIDENTS NOR IS IT
A- PROVIDED THEM FOR EXAMPLE
TESSA SINUSES P. RECIPIENTS-
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF ACTIONS
WE HAVE TAKEN THAT WORD
BUDGETARY TO RESPOND TO THE
CRISIS THAT WERE TIME SENSITIVE
AND URGENT AND THIS IS
ADDITIONALLY ONE OF THOSE
BECAUSE- THE PANDEMIC CLOSURES
WERE. IMPOSED TO DO A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY SO FOLKS WERE
LAID OFF DUE TO THAT AND WE ARE
THE BUDGETARY ASPECT IS BOTH TO
RESPOND TO THE FACT THAT OUR
GOVERNOR HAS. LEGITIMATELY
ANNOUNCED THE RE PENING OF THE
ECONOMY AND THAT ADDITIONALLY
THIS IS A SECTOR THAT. LOST
SOME OF THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
WORKERS AND THE DIVISION. WE
HAVE MADE SOME CHANGES TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THIS RE HIRING
THAT THERE IS ENFORCEMENT
SOLELY AND ONLY UNDER THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT-
DIVISION IN WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER BUT I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BACKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO HI CORTESE
HI DALLY NO DODD. NO THE RAZA
HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ
HI GROVE NO HERTZBERG. HI HUESO.
HER TADO NO JONES. NO KAMLAGER.
FIVE LAYERED HI LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A CHIRLA
BOTH NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
I'M BURKE. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK NOW. PLEASE
CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
BRADFORD GLAZER. HUESO HI.
AMBERG HI. FIVE TWENTY FIVE
NEWS ELEVENTH THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO ROUTE MOVE ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE SENATOR LIKE HEALTHY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
RELATIVE TO TAMIL HERITAGE
MONTH DAY. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ARE HEALTHY THIS
RESOLUTION TECH CELEBRATES TOM
HERITAGE THOMAS ORIGINALLY FROM
THE SOUTHERN STATE OF TAMIL
NADU IN INDIA THE TOM LANGUAGE
IS A LONGER SURVIVES THE
SURVIVING CLASSICAL LANGUAGE IN
THE WORLDTHAT'S A CLASSICAL
LANGUAGE WITH THE TRACEABLE
HISTORY EXCEEDING TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED YEARS CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER. SIXTY THOUSAND
TOM OF FAMILIES MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CALIFORNIA
APPROVEDTOM OF FOR SCHOOL-
CREDITS IN MY OWN DISTRICT
HOPKINS JUNIOR HIGHS HOSTED BY
SUCH A- SITUATION NOTABLE
TAMILS IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDE
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
WHO'S HAS HER MATERNAL ROOTS IN
CHENNAI. MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
FREMONT CITY COUNCIL THE NEW
NOT TO RUSSIAN WAS THE FIRST
INDIAN AMERICAN OF TOMBALL
DESCENT TO BE ELECTED TO HAVE.
A CITY COUNCIL THE TOM
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE GLOBE
CELEBRATED ITS FOR ITS NEW
YEAR'S YESTERDAY APRIL
FOURTEENTH KNOWN AS THE FIRST
DAY OF CHIEF AND RAY. I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER RIGHT SKI MEMBERS ANY
TO. AND OR TO. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLENHI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BAKER. FIVE FORTUS I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY. HI DODD. HI
THE RAZA. HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO.
HI JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MILLION. FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BY TELEPHONE.
HI PAM HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI WHITE HOUSE SKI.
FIVE WIENER HI WILK. HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NIELSEN HI WELL FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OF OUR CHAIRS
COULD ANNOUNCE THEIR COMMITTEES
THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC. I'M
LOOKING FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE
SENATOR WIENER CENTREBOARD
JUSTIN CENTER LAYERED CENTER
FOR JUST. THANK YOU BEEN
PRESENT- SENATE COMMITTEE WILL
MEET UPON GERMAN IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE HE'LL BE A SHORT
MEETING. PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND NOT A
PRESIDENTE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE MEETING AT TEN
FIFTEEN IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE CENTER LAYERED ON
NATURAL RESOURCES WILL BE
MEETING AND FORTY TWO OR THREE
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE CENTER
LAYERED SENATOR WIENER. BUT
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING HERE ON THE FLOOR AT
TEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER. IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS TO
DISCUSS CLEAR. PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL I WILL ADD IS
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND AND OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION SCHEDULED
FOR MONDAY APRIL NINETEENTH AT
TWO PM TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MADAM PROGRAM THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM. HAVE A GREAT DAY MEMBERS.